My dear citizens that are watching us in
front of their televisions dear friends
from across the world who have their
eyes and hearts turned to Turkey dear
brothers and sisters I would like to
welcome each and every one of you with
heartfelt emotions starting from the
night of the 15th of July Turkey
experienced one of its most critical
days in history the Turkish Armed Forces
within the Turkish Armed Forces which is
of course our pride of nation the pride
of our nation and country a group
nestled in the Turkish Armed Forces
broke the chain of command and attempted
a coup those individuals in this group
understood to be members of the good and
his terrorist organization attacked its
state and its nation using planes
helicopters tanks and all kinds of
weaponry the presidential complex the
Grand National Assembly of Turkey the
premises of the offices of the prime
minister the chief of staff the general
command the campus of the Turkish
national intelligence agency the
Bosphorus Bridge and various military
units were heavily attacked thanks to
the determined stance of me and my
government and of course the fact that
our nation stood in the way of those who
plotters and as a result of the
effective interventions of our security
forces
this attempt never succeeded and in the
face of our nation taking of its country
and of its determination the weapons the
tanks the helicopters and the planes of
the coup plotters amounted to nothing
against terrorists in military fatigues
the people stood a price and
took ownership of their homeland and
their future and our nation Rhodes
epics heroic bravery throughout the
night we had the young the old the
employers the bosses villages the urban
settlers every member of our nation came
together as one entity in the face of
this attempt citizens that said no to
this
so tens of people being shot and being
motorized and in front of their eyes and
of course they saw numerous people get
wounded and injured they tried to save
instances and until the early hours of
the morning they continued their
resistance thanks to God every one that
feels themselves to be a member of this
homeland and of this nation stood in the
our nation had the sorrow of not being
able to save men Duras and his friends
and colleagues in the aftermath of the
coup in the aftermath of the coup in
1980 young people were executed abiding
by the idea of one from the right and
one from the left those subjects are
still fresh in our memory and 15th of
July 2016 is a turning point when the
nation put an end to this field faith
for the first time in the history of our
country who attempt was crippled by the
nation itself and actually proposed its
allegiance to democracy and to the rule
of law by paying a very high price which
is the
of its citizens as a result of the fire
and shootings the coup plotters 246
innocent citizens police officers and
military personnel lost their lives 1536
innocents evidence citizens were also
wounded on this occasion I would like to
honor the memory of the Fallen and I
would like to wish speedy recovery to
the wounded I would like to convey my
condolences to the relatives and
families of those that lost their lives
I want to be very clear of course it's
not no time to be dwelling on this as
the president of this nation country of
my people it will be row ik act of
bravery from the hand of the Turkish
nation loved' citizens from the first
moment the coup attempt president myself
the Prime Minister's ministers security
forces and commanders of the armed
forces that stood against it all came
together and worked in a very close
collaboration despite all dangers and
all threats I headed out to Istanbul
immediately and with my nation of course
I stood against in the face of the
determination and the will of my nation
the attempt was completely before the
night or the evening of the following
day and today on the twenty
July we had the meeting of the National
Security Council which was then followed
by a meeting of the Council of Ministers
the members of the neither did intensive
we decided to recommend to the
government that a state of emergency be
declared as per article 120 of our
Constitution in order for us to be able
to speedily and Swift the deal with all
of the elements of the terrorist
organization and the Council of
Ministers also abided by that
recommendation and decided to declare a
state of emergency for a duration of
three months as it is known article 120
of our Constitution allows for a state
of emergency to be declared in the event
of acts of violence that aim to abolish
democracy and fundamental rights
and the purpose of the declaration of
the state of emergency is in fact to be
able to take the most efficient steps in
order to remove this threat as possible
which is to the right of our citizens in
our country absolutely not against it
has the purpose and the key by risking
their lives and who are trying to impose
their dictatorship our government our
political parties are safe
Society and the chain of command and
destroyed our most important nation
always they have always shown that their
preference is on the side of democracy
mr. Muhsin than it was on this occasion
I would like to also convey my deepest
gratitude to my citizens starting from
the night of the 15th of July that went
to the squares and they stayed there
regardless of their political party
political thought or all of my citizens
that stood in the way of Tanks are to be
like the heroes channel or Gallipoli
battles they are to be likened to the
Lions as described by merit our chief
the poet so they stood in the way of the
tanks with all of their courage and they
even risked being martyred Hibiki there
are very large the childish thermos
architecture Masada this brother and
unfortunately we had to part ways with
friends of many years who were killed
during the incidents so a lady of 32
years of age was also killed after she
was rushed by a tank
these people are so heinous
as to and squash a young woman by using
tammany that is how cruel these people
are so that lady is now a martyr so they
did not contend with that they did not
stop but my nation our nation did not
stop
tenders were shot and wounded despite
that for hours citizens did not leave or
their positions and they have proven
that they are the descendants of the war
of independence there were warplanes
flying at low altitude helicopters fired
using heavy military fatigues despite
all of these things my brothers and
sisters did not leave did not desert the
street leaves me much gone worse
describes have also been occupying the
streets and the scores on a democracy
watch saw that the same thing cannot be
attempted again and their names will go
down in golden letters in memory of in
this history of democracies for even
today starting from 4 p.m. people
started flocking to visualize square
right now there are thousands of them in
tens of thousands of people are in Konya
having a video conferencing session
possession with them and I will be
addressing those crowds on Canada
goodbye